it's called polyandry one woman several
husbands it's an unusual arrangement
today polyandry only persists in
isolated villages in the Himalayans when
it was time for Sunita Kumari with her
family like many in India made
arrangements but they involve more than
a doubt celebration Sunita has not one
husband not two systems but three all
brothers
what muster life be like
Westerners might find the practice
shocking but for this community it works
fine
one reason sheer practicality in the
Himalayas arable land of scarce farms
are tiny if each generation divided each
family's holdings everyone would starve
polyandry preserves the farm and the
family's future unlike most men in India
husband's here handle domestic duties
they're willing to help with the cooking
and childcare in fraternal polyandry a
family picks a wife for its oldest son
the marriage can also include his
younger brothers they don't have to join
in but most do no one takes a decision
regarding one's own marriage everyone at
home sits down together and then it's
decided with the consent of everyone
polyandry also functions as a form of
birth control
no matter how many husbands she has a
wife can get pregnant only so often if
each man were to Wed separately the
population here would explode but what
about sex
the forbidden core of a polyandry taboo
in truth it's a matter of scheduling and
on the wife's part forbearance is very
important the wife has to understand
everything the older brother's nature
the younger brothers nature had Toto
make you say what about jealousy that
vain of even the most mundane marriage
if the wife is smart she will take turns
each night asleep with all the brothers
let's get wives in India I say
it's not like the older brother wants or
old Todd I thought okay who knows until
recently no one here much cared what the
outside world thought isolation had
preserved a way of life that had
withered everywhere else but a road now
links the region to distant cities and
on roofs once decorated only with prayer
flags satellite dishes sprout this
village has entered the modern world
whose images of romance stand in sharp
contrast to polyamory but polyamory here
faces a bigger threat education as more
people are becoming more educated we are
also practicing the family planning if a
father has only one son there will be no
question about the land therefore common
marriages will come to an end in two
perhaps three generations polyandry may
vanish here but for now those who
practices find comfort in the familiar
feel that common marriage is very good I
feel like everyone should live like our
family even if we do not have anything
to eat or drink we sit happily we live
peacefully